[Mark] And you can just see all of those juices just mingling together within the bun.
What's up everyone it's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com in Bangkok, Thailand.
It is a blazing hot afternoon, and I had a little bit of a craving for a burger,
so we are on our way to go eat a delicious burger in Bangkok.
We're going with Ying, and Phoenicia and Dwight as well right now.
Dwight and I actually had a craving for burgers since yesterday,
so we had to make that craving come true!
Oh yeah, I can actually smell the grilling onions from down the street
[Ying] Yeah!
[Mark] We made it to this place which is called Daniel Thaiger,
and Daniel Thaiger is a street food hamburger truck.
And they're kind of, kind of were the pioneers when it comes to the Bangkok burger movement
Burgers are very popular in Bangkok now
and they were some of the pioneers, and they still serve one of the best burgers in Bangkok.
They have kind of shifted a number of different locations
But their location right now is right on Soi 30/1, which is actually right on the outside fence of the Philippine Embassy.
And they have a truck set up,
they have a nice little seating area, a couple of tables, or you can just kind of stand around here and eat.
So here's the menu and you can either choose beef or pork, and then they have a couple of different set burgers:
the Thaiger, the Mr. Steve, the Cowboy, the Sumo Oat, and then some other toppings that you can add on.
Trying to contemplate which burger to order ... I'm thinking of just going with the Thaiger.
But I may have to ... actually, it might have to be the Mr. Steve because of that bacon.
Okay Mr. Steve it is, maybe with an extra patty.
My mouth is watering anticipating this burger.
You can just hear the sizzling of that beef and the aroma.
Maybe it's because Bangkok is so humid,
literally the aroma of beef just fills the entire air.
So we had to snack on some french fries as we're waiting for our burgers to finish cooking.
Humidity. It's like half water in the air and half burger juices.
It's like burger humidity, that's what it is!
Oh yeah, the burgers have arrived. Dwight has already started eating his burger
How is it man? So I can just increase my anticipation.
[Dwight] Umm it's great, and it's getting better.
[Mark] Haha!
[Dwight] As usual I've ordered mine medium, I think you order yours a little rarer than this, but this is how I like it,
[Mark] Oh what is this dude?
[Dwight] Animal style fries with some crispy bacon, jalapenos and
their Thaiger sauce all over them.
[Mark] Oh wow! Should we try this real fast before
we're dipping into the burger?
[Dwight] I'm double-fisting already so...
[Mark] Okay, I will hold this. Let's just sample this immediately.
There are jalapenos on here, there's bacon, there are onions
and some orange-y sauce.
Oh yeah!
Well, that's awesome.
Really crispy fries, but it's not too oily, not too greasy
and then, yes, good bacon, really crunchy bacon on there,
sour jalapenos and then just fried onions.
I got the Mr. Steve and I decided to go with the double patties which I'm not sure...
yes, it was definitely a necessary move. And then I got them medium rare.
Oh and already just feeling my fingers on the bun, you can feel the bun is really soft.
It is a brioche-style bun, and then they wrap it in a piece of paper,
and there is bacon on here, the two patties, cheese right in the middle of the patties, sauce,
there are tomatoes and lettuce, and you can just see all of those juices just just mingling together within the bun.
[Mark] I'm gonna need to lean over for this one
[Ying] Mm-hmm.
[Mark] I'm gonna need to lean over a little bit.
All right, my first bite.
Oh wow!
That's incredible!
Mmm, the bun has a really nice buttery flavor to it.
It's really really soft, and then the meat is so tender
Oh that meat it's so juicy and tender. One of the things that they really emphasize here is that they always use
freshly ground beef. So it's never frozen, never frozen patties, and
just fresh, ground beef. And they seasoned it with just, I think, some salt and pepper, and then she
she fried it in some Worcestershire sauce I think. And I think that was about it and
It is just like simple perfection in a bun.
That is amazing. There's so much meat
within this bun!
This is a burger where it it does get a little bit of messy, so you definitely need to have some tissue on hand.
All right.
That's almost everything you want in a burger.
It's so juicy, and then the meat is so fresh tasting,
the bacon is crispy, but thick at the same time,
and then the sauce is a little bit tangy,
a little bit mayonnaise-y,
and then, yeah, cheese to wrap it all up, and then just multiple juices coming out from everywhere.
I'm getting to the bottom portion of the burger, loving every single bite of it, and I think it's time to
release the burger from the paper.
Oh yes, oh!
There's just a pool of juices and sauce at the bottom.
Oh but what I'm really loving about this burger
is, well the beef is definitely the highlight, but the beef how it's medium-rare cooked,
it's so juicy and so so tender. It's kind of like half ... it tastes like like grilled
tartare, like minced ... Oh, it's just, it's just awesomely good.
Oh baby.
So incredibly juicy.
Hmm. I'm down to my final bite.
I'm just gonna soak up a little more of those juices and sauces from the bottom of the paper.
Ho ho ho oh yeah
I wouldn't say that you have to order the two burger patties,
but I would say that it was well well worth it.
It was incredible to have that much meat within the burger and that much juicy fresh meat as well.
I think that's definitely what really stood out to me is the beef.
Ah, just you can taste the difference between frozen beef and beef that's freshly ground, never frozen.
Really good burger. I actually rarely ever eat burgers,
even though I do fully enjoy burgers, and this was an amazing burger
if you are looking for gourmet street food truck burgers in Bangkok,
Daniel Thaiger is excelling at making them.
Thank you all for watching this video,
please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it and leave a comment below.
And also make sure you subscribe for lots more food and travel videos.
And I will see you on the next video.
<beep>
It's just an all around just a wonderful burger. Thank you all very much for watching this burger.
<laughs>